what a week for the queen bee
it started the MTV Video Music Awards
where fiance broke Madonna's record for
most wins ever and she's celebrating a
milestone birthday counting down to the
big 3/5 and slaying at courtside sitting
pretty at the US Open yesterday in New
York City with hubby jay-z score love
love the power couple were cheering on
good friend Serena Williams who knocked
her 306 career grand slam win
I'm just before blue IBM before she
served as lemonade this was a young 18
year old Beyonce on her way to
superstardom as part of Destiny's Child
it wouldn't be long before everyone knew
her name and her unmatched tally I don't
like to get my head then I hate getting
makeup done I take quick showers not
luxurious fast I don't get pedicures and
manicures as often as I shoot I'm just a
very earthy chick from cute to Sasha
Fierce the singer has matured right
before our eyes
what's the best thing about being a mom
so far I have such a full life I feel
like now I know the reason why I was
born and to ring in her 35th year one
Sunday the multi Grammy winner will
reportedly host a Soul Train theme party
in New York I'm always changing trying
to always go and I would just want to do
something different I got hot sauce in
my bag swag